still a lot of so a lot of great show
coming up so stick around but recently I
don't have to mention this we had some
very exciting news here at the
late-night show one of our own has been
nominated for a Grammy Award that's
right I'm talking about our good friend
triumph the insult comic dog received
we're not making this up triumph
received a Grammy nomination for his
debut album come poop with me now yeah
that's um that's it's just proving that
just class lasts and well obviously we
were all thrilled for triumph couldn't
wait to see him on the Grammys in fact
Warner Brothers triumphs record company
asked the CBS network if triumph could
be one of the presenters on the show
because that's normally what happens
people who are up for a Grammy usually
present get this CBS said no that's
right they thought triumph was quote too
unpredictable for a live primetime
family-orientated broadcast well I'm
sorry but I think this is an outrage I
can think of no one no one better suited
to be a presenter on a prime-time awards
show than triumph the insult comic dog
in fact we wanted to show CBS what a
colossal mistake they've made by
allowing triumph tonight to do a
practice Grammy Award presentation right
here on our show we're practically live
so is that cool with you thank you
to help triumph demonstrate his
professionalism we've enlisted the
legendary frontman for the cars Ric
Ocasek he's going to be co-presenter and
let's do this right now
take a look presenting the award for
best song of the year
here's the car wrinkled Cassidy and
triumph the insult comic dog
yes it's great to be out here with a
bona fide rock legend like Ric Ocasek
well you know it's not surprising that
we're presenting together triumph after
all you know how much dogs like to chase
cars and like your great song that was
just what I needed makes me long for
Hollywood Squares triumph come on just
take it easy we're trying to show that
you're professional come on are you
kidding me this bantha is about this
smooth as my poop after a peanut binge
triumphs look what you did you blew it
no no I can do it I can do this give me
another shot please pardon all right
I'll give you another shot if you say so
quit try this again Joel presenting the
Award for Best Song of the Year cards
frontman
everyone it's so great to be presenting
with the real legend here Ric Ocasek yes
well it's not surprising that we're
presenting together triumph after all
you know how much dogs like to chase
cars even better the second time okay
the nominees for song of the year the
reason by Hoobastank hey Hoobastank you
buck mine for yeah by Usher yeah by
Usher come on that song stinks worse
than Kirstie Alley's bday
[Applause]
put me up to it
no I didn't I didn't put you up oh come
on no give me one more chance Olive Oyl
took the bus all the way from Soho
triumph triumph you can have one more
chance but we're running out of time
let's do it let's do it all right
once again Odessa and triumph the insult
comic door thank you everyone it's great
to be here with a bona fide rock legend
like Ric Ocasek that's Ric Ocasek easy
scarecrow they're you up for Best in
Show trying Oh Grammy [ __ ] and look
at this guy
you look like Richard Belzer bang the
Wolfhound okay triumph that's not right
rick is a rock legend yeah The Legend of
Sleepy Hollow you're a star
come on the last time you made a teenage
girl scream was when your balls flopped
out of your swim trunks if you agree
with some of us that triumph should be
allowed to present at the Grammys after
that incredibly professional performance
please write the Grammys care of CBS
Studios Hollywood California
we'll be right back Randy Jackson